-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers,
this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Last night was Super Bowl LVII,
and out of habit,
Biden shot down
the Goodyear blimp.
[ Laughter ]
The so-called "He gets us"
campaign ran two commercials
during the Super Bowl last night
to promote Jesus
and Christianity.
However, thanks to the referees,
Philadelphia no longer believes
in God.
[ Laughter ]
During her halftime show
performance at last night's
Super Bowl, Rihanna revealed
she was pregnant,
while the rest of us
just ate like we were.
[ Laughter ]
According to new analysis,
more than 50 million Americans
were expected to gamble
this year on the Super Bowl.
By serving Buffalo wings
in a one-bathroom apartment.
[ Laughter ]
-Elon Musk was photographed
last night at the Super Bowl
sitting next to Fox chairman
Rupert Murdoch.
I think we have a photo.
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
The State Department today
issued a do not travel advisory
for Russia.
Yeah, we weren't planning on it.
"Bad news, kids. I know you had
your hearts set on
going to the Kremlin, but looks
like we're going to do Disney."
The State Department said last
week that the downed
Chinese spy balloon was carrying
surveillance equipment capable
of intercepting communications.
They needed someone on spying
on people who still haven't
downloaded TikTok.
[ Laughter ]
The FBI announced on Friday
that it found
an additional
classified document
at former Vice President
Mike Pence's Indiana home.
Even weirder, they found it in
a file marked "work stuff."
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, it actually is work stuff."
An owl was recently removed from
a college library in Georgia.
And this is annoying --
now it's saying "whom."
[ Laughter ]
My two favorite things,
Shoemaker, owls and grammar.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Texas
recently responded to a report
of two goats on the loose
in a Target store.
The goats were captured and
safely returned
to T.J. Maxx.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a woman in Chile
set a Guinness World Record
after swimming about 1.5 miles
in Antarctic water.
Said the woman, "Can someone
please rescue me?!"
[ Laughter ]
And once again,
we've miscalculated
what our closer was.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
We're done. Owl --
should have closed with owl.